foreign
[Music]
Ty for Brady's starting lineup
Lily Tomlin Wayne State University Rita
Moreno
ps132 Sally Field Birmingham High School
Jane Fonda College Dropout the 80 for
Brady trailer starts in three two one
game's about to start oh there's Tom Oh
What a Beautiful I like Gronkowski we
know Chris we've all read your grunk
erotica it's not erotica it's fan
fiction very sexy fan fiction
aren't you tired of the same old boring
lives let's go to the Super Bowl the
Super Bowl is no place for four old
women this could be Tom's last one he's
almost 40. that's like 80 in people
years yeah we're 80 in people years I
just really need this trip
[Music]
I can't believe we're actually here
taking this one he's cute so you don't
have any tickets how much for four ten
thousand ten thousand well I have a 20
in my strap-on that's a fanny pack if
you work like this it's a strap-on wow
so great to meet your beauty has no
expiration date Chris I didn't flirt he
did there's so much here to do he could
even win these tickets this is The Spicy
Wings contest I could use a little spice
I know her you blackout who you want me
to call
an ambulance
if you did this to give us something to
remember why honey didn't work do you
think you could get us in follow me
these are my dancers prove it what dance
moves you ladies know a Twist a jerk
let's do it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm free
these are good very good oh careful
they're high dosage high dosage
excuse me I'm looking for someone are
you okay
I'm Guy Fieri
[Music]
foreign
[Music]